quand le beau temps revienne des
centaines de travailleurs maigreux vers
le grand nord québécois partent
travailler faire de l'argent mais
certains d'entre eux débarquent dans les
villages du nunavik avec de mauvaises
intentions
je n'ai pas envie pour leur chaloupe au
lait de coco
plusieurs travailleurs savent qu'en
échange d'alcool il pourra obtenir des
faveurs sexuelles des jeunes inuits
notre collègue josée dupuis est allé à
leur rencontre
si certains d'entre eux vont jusqu'à
commettre des agressions sexuelles
parfois en toute impunité
la loi est la même pour tout le monde
dans les cas d'agression sexuelle mais
tu vois pas aussi comme les autres c'est
tout fait part en blanc c'est sûr
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
village de beauté unique
niché au creux des montagnes près du
détroit du de son salut 8 est l'une des
communautés les plus au nord du québec
on y accède que par avion
[Musique]
ici vivent près de 1700 personnes fin
octobre 2013
c'est déjà l'hiver
le pick up roule lentement et emprunte
la longue route qui mène vers l'aéroport
à bord deux jeunes filles louit de 15 et
16 ans au volant un homme blanc de 27
ans le pick up quitte la route enneigée
et prend un autre chemin celui du
dépotoir
la nuit va bientôt tomber seul wit est
soudainement bien loin
le véhicule s'avance parmi les débris
puis s'arrête soudain le silence un
silence glacial
[Musique]
cathy papy gâteau qui a voulu nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé ce soir là
elle a accepté que l'on dévoile son nom
que l'on entende sa voix mais par pudeur
elle a préféré cacher son visage ni sa
soeur que l'âne est assise à l'arrière
du camion
impuissante à washington
un come on
[Musique]
hightower centers trois épisodes à
taïwan tourisme est un il y à cathy mais
aussi plusieurs autres des femmes inuit
qui ont subi les outrages de certains
blancs montés au nord pour travailler
des femmes déjà très fragilisée qui ont
le courage et toutes les raisons du
monde de prononcer ce mot lourd de sens
ce thème est assez morose
[Musique]
katimavik haddouk lui fait visiter sa
chambre où dort paisiblement son bébé
trois mois une chambre à soi c'est un
luxe au nunavik c'est son refuge
[Musique]
sa vie a changé depuis la naissance de
ce petit garçon elle ne boit plus ne
fait plus de cannabis
[Musique]
paul tanner
what to do list d'arsène wenger die zeit
is right les vignes parce qu'elle espère
tôt ou tard en 2013 cathy à 15 ans il
marche avec sa soeur kellan dans les
rues de saint louis et la bu un petit le
travailleur de la construction les
aborde les invite à monter avec lui
faire un tour et à retomber à mon égard
[Musique]
c'est dans sa langue en hymne aux petits
tout que katy a choisi d'exprimer ce
qu'elle a ressenti ce soir-là à nyala
[Musique]
malgré ces mauvais
en augmentant le rythme
[Musique]
le travailleur les ramènent ensuite au
village et les poussent à l'extérieur au
lycée
tampa bay
il se prend à rêver
quelques jours plus tard cathy va porter
plainte au poste de police de saint
louis 8 puis en 2010 est cette jeune
femme au visage et au corps d'enfant
reverra son agresseur en cours une étape
difficile mais décisive à 15 heures
daniel bilodeau a plaidé coupable à un
chef d'accusation réduit d'agression
sexuelle à l'endroit d'une mineure selon
sa version des faits cathy lui aurait
dit qu'elle avait 20 ans il dit aussi
que c'est elle qui lui aurait fait des
avances et qu'il n'y a pas eu
pénétration
en ou 2017
bilodeau a été condamné à 240 jours de
prison pour le procureur de la couronne
cette peine est tout à fait approprié
que la jeune fille
le seul moment
dans le futur alors des conséquences
plus important de savoir des
conséquences très importantes
cette jeune fille sa défense loïc dit
que j'allais construction la communauté
ici ce sera la venue de brive l'avocat
alain arsenault a participé à l' enquête
nationale sur les femmes et les filles
autochtones disparues et assassinées
il connaît bien le milieu pour lui les
propos du procureur sont déconcertants à
écouter la représentation des faits non
seulement c'est pas la grèce manquer la
victime on semble dans la présentation
des fêtes par la couronne a réduit
énormément les les faits d'agression
comme on peut même se demander si en une
agression alors pourquoi cette mort
pourquoi pourquoi at il plaidé coupable
face à la déclaration du procureur de la
couronne le juge jean-pierre gervais
exprime un certain malaise
on me dise que de prime abord semble pas
y avoir de conséquences
mais plus tard il dit vouloir préciser
sa pensée je reproche à personne de dire
que peu de conséquences parce qu'on est
face à des visiteuses qui plus liberté
qui pue l'accident on se retrouve dans
une société qui a à plusieurs égards le
sous-indice fonctionnel ce n'est pas une
société du bertone
les gens sont des victimes d'agressions
sexuelles les femmes à 75 penser ça n'en
fera pas des libertines ses divisions et
velours pour marié qui courent parce que
ce genre de situation on doit écouter
qu'on doit dénoncer une grue depuis
trois ans après des connaissances à
damas que c'est possible
le nom de daniel me ledoux est désormais
inscrit au registre des délinquants
sexuels et y restera durant dix ans
daniel bilodeau devait être dans un
centre de réinsertion sociale
pourtant lorsque nous sommes pas assez
les employés ne l'avait pas vu depuis
deux jours impossible de savoir où il se
trouve
l'information est confidentiel bilodeau
et puis maintenant commentaires les plus
nous avons contacté son ancien employeur
la compagnie génie construction qui
n'était pas au courant du comportement
de son ex employée gili a refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue elle soutient que
ces travailleurs reçoivent des
directives très claires avant de se
rendre au nunavik et que la consommation
d'alcool est interdite
on
après cet événement la soeur de katy a
quitté sa louit cayla ne vit maintenant
à montréal où elle cherche du travail
les couloirs du métro ont remplacé les
grands espaces nordiques ont montré leur
tour à tour
le taux d'agressions sexuelles au
nunavik est effarant selon les chiffres
de 2010 est fourni par la police
régionale kativik 220 cas implique des
mineurs et 226 des adultes sur une
population d'un peu plus de 12 mille
habitants une femme sur trois aurait été
agressé durant l'enfance
ce ne sont que les cas rapportés la
majorité ne le sont pas la plupart des
agresseurs sont inuit les traumatismes
passés l'alcool la drogue et la très
grande promiscuité dû au logement
surpeuplé contribuer à cette triste
réalité les signatures de deux kits moi
je signe à tous les jours où
pratiquement tous les jours on parle de
ça maintenant c'est comme une ou deux
jours mais est plus question
ok ce ne sont pas que des résidences ne
sont pas que des inuit qui sont les
auteurs de ces crimes non iodé blé un
gamin
michelle martin est le chef de police du
nunavik c'est le grand patron qui
supervise la sécurité des 14 villages
soit le tiers du territoire québécois
michelle martin a été en poste durant
trois ans et vient tout juste de
terminer son mandat
ce policier d'expérience et est sorti de
sa retraite pour venir donner un coup de
main au nord selon lui certains
travailleurs profitent de cette détresse
et en rajoute ce qui est ciblée sur un
cd jeunes filles du duo travaillé pour
les nations unies
on le voit dans le cadre des opérations
internationales
mais c'est la même chose ici au québec
pour preuve la main au canada au nunavut
des gens qui viennent pour des courtes
périodes bon milieu isolé opportunités
et peut-être plus facile moins de
compétition et peut-être une clientèle
plus vulnérables surtout en se faisant
offrir des cadeaux mais un échange
d'alcool ou de drogue
ça devient un moyen le désaltérer et de
profiter de ces jeunes femmes l'eau
l'alcool c'est l'ex ir qui endort la
douleur le mal de vivre et troublent la
mémoire trois villages seulement
permettent la vente libre d'alcool dans
les 11 autres il est permis d'en
commander une certaine quantité
malgré tout il est omniprésent c'est
michel d'arriver ici par exemple ça les
mecs tonkov du team tu es notre coffre
plein de bouteilles de boissons tout en
lien ici
potec des intentions qui sont peut-être
pas saine jean-mathieu lafleur a été
positive durant 14 ans au nunavik il a
quitté ses fonctions en 2016
il se rappelle encore l'une de ses
premières interventions dans un camp de
construction un homme dans la
quarantaine avait attiré dans sa chambre
une jeune fille de 14 ans on se retrouve
à passer au travers certains visiblement
s'était passé quelque chose
la jeune fille s'est enfui à l'arrivée
du policier et personne n'a porté
plainte
j'ai jamais été capable de damas et de
la preuve dans ce dossier là
malheureusement parce que j'ai jamais
été capable d'avoir aucune collaboration
le sport à l'époque musique est un genre
de règles avec les compagnies de
construction tels individus allaient
être mis sur le prochain avion ait
quitté le village fait pour qui la
possède aussi criminel et ça c'est à
rethel
[Musique]
les situations comme celle-là il en a vu
souvent à pourrir nous tous oui je les
ai vu intervenir directement à l'autre
de l'aco sortir des jeunes filles
intoxiqué il y avait du grabuge
les chambres de l'hôtel avec des gens de
la construction
gentleman ce travail dans le bar de
l'hôtel de coups de joie du côté de
l'ungava pas
jeannie pas piquer tous qui est
originaire de saint louis 8
elle vit aujourd'hui dans les
laurentides avec ses trois enfants
cet artiste accomplie a été une certaine
époque
une de ces jeunes adolescentes qui
tournait autour des travailleurs jeannie
a préféré témoigner de profil
car affronter l'oeil de la caméra lui
était trop difficile
elle conserve de se passer une certaine
honte
admin et frank engel george orwell fanga
nabil obtained a été testé peut-être art
show johnny moss
[Musique]
tous les étés elle attendait l'arrivée
des gars de la construction
woods a commis neuf sorties semaine
comme à des indemnités d'un louis triaud
l'ivoiro rich schultz ni le des pick up
sentance des données weight watchers
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est
elle n'a jamais porté plainte
à 15 ans elle croyait être consentante
elle a mis du temps à réaliser le tort
que cela lui avait fait bad know it goes
can now ta race noire high tech charge
hors d'eau sur le puits pour noms d'atos
report à une date après la pause
i wanna go
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le beau temps marque le début de la
saison de la construction au nunavik
leçons des marteaux résonnent dans la
plupart des 14 villages préparation
rénovation construction de logements des
besoins sont immenses
l'arrivée du bateau de ravitaillement
déclenche aussi une certaine
effervescence
jean jacques morisset nous reçoit dans
les nouveaux locaux du land holdings à
saint-louis pl c'est le land holdings
qui encore des permis aux compagnies
construction en juillet dernier quatre
compagnies répartis dans deux camps de
construction et des sous traitants se
sont partagés les ouvrages
c'est près d'une centaine de
travailleurs qui envahissent le village
doucement serait soumis à un code de
conduite rien avoir semble-t-il avec ce
qui se passait il ya vingt ans vous il
ya 20 ans était le plus fort
oui un dantin il y avait des
contracteurs qui accorde des contenants
de boissons dans la langue la 87 ans est
arrivé ici il y avait des combattants
comme ça c'est comme un porte ouvert
juste un an à la seconde tu vois les
familles rente son caractère deux ans
après il sent qu'ils ont su aujourd'hui
une compagnie comme makivik construction
nous dit on a des règles très strictes à
pau doit d'apporter boissons tabac doit
d'avoir relations dans la village comme
ça on essaye de faire la même chose avec
d autres compagnies makivik n'a pas
voulu nous montrer son code d'éthique
même chose pour les principales
compagnies qui oeuvrent au nunavik pépin
fortin laval fortin adam fcmq
construction seul w esprit nous a fait
parvenir le site
toutes ces compagnies ont refusé nos
demandes d'entrevue pour le land
holdings de cellou et si une compagnie
contrevient aux règles
la décision est sans appel le permis lui
est retiré
c'est ce qui est arrivé à la compagnie
edc nord laisse trop de ces vidanges
partout ils sont avec des femmes est nul
dans les villages
y'a pas des femmes deux villages dans ce
fait tout sous ya un portillon gitane et
de c'est vous qui avez dit c'est moins
que dia laborde
il y avait des plaintes à d autres
villages
si on n'a pas donné un permis pour
travailler nous avons contacté le
président de la compagnie edc nord
stéphane plante
il a refusé de répondre à nos questions
concernant les agissements de certains
de ses employés
la compagnie a fait faillite en 2010 est
[Musique]
il ya trois ans une autre compagnie a
fait parler d'elle au nunavik c'est
genivar construction dans le petit
village de couacs tac
ces travailleurs ont démoli un camp de
construction à la suite d'une soirée qui
a dégénéré nous avons joint au téléphone
à pâques tac
les propriétaires du camp que louer
genivar construction adami kulula et
bertha adams
ils ont pas vraiment défendre les murs
parce que les occupants tout le temps il
y avait une femme qui a marché
tout n'est pas tout le temps y avait
quelques fans qui sont allés la police a
dû intervenir
nous avons joint genivar construction
ils reconnaissent les faits il affirme
que des mesures disciplinaires ont été
prises et que certains travailleurs ont
été mis à pied et soutiennent qu'il n'y
avait aucune mineurs sur les lieux
toutes les femmes à qui nous avons parlé
avec quelque chose à dire sur la
présence de ces travailleurs eva abraham
vit à saint louis depuis 26 ans
haïti doit payer l'équivalent niang
moment you think you des guettes missned
mn ce rapport comme l'a été sa fille
aînée touch ios système d'arrosage et
ncr match lâchait l'aude et chez toi ni
ça peut être vus comme des cas isolés
monsieur les grizzlies qui se répète
assez souvent est-ce que ça demeure des
cas isolés
je pense pas par l'oci sabia juke et le
maire de saint louis 8
il est très conscient du tort que
certains cause à sa communauté et en du
mieux qu'il peut y mettre un terme
moussaoui wacker pour benzema widgets
internet du quotidien de tout temps
constitué en euros en happy pour leurs
sound pour qui mise au lit du colosse
est-ce que ça qu'on sent que les trahir
la construction ont connu des gens de
l'est des centres de santé déjà
maintenant différente des différences
des différentes organisations nunavik
on est des interventions avec des
membres du gouvernement régional la
commission scolaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pouvant ni taux troisième plus gros
villages du nunavik
alexandre petit 30 ans travaille à
d'épicerie
il a l'habitude d'inviter chez lui de
très jeunes collègues de travail sa
femme est là mais se couche tôt une fois
seul alexandre petit fait boire ses
invités en retour de faveurs sexuelles
ces victimes ont à l'époque 14 et 15 ans
les agressions sont commises sur une
période de six mois
deux adolescentes vont porter plainte
alexandre petit est accusé d'agression
sexuelle et de contacts sexuels sur deux
mineures est passible de 14 ans de
prison en juin 2017
on laisse tomber des accusations
d'agression sexuelle alexandre petit
plaide coupable à gatineau à des
accusations réduites de contact sexuel
et d'agression armée de madame avec un
balai cmq avec un hub à l'époque était
présente un certain moment mais surtout
chez il est condamné à 90 jours de
prison à purger les fins de semaine il
est aujourd'hui en liberté
mais tout comme l'agresseur de cathy son
nom est aussi inscrit au registre des
délinquants sexuels pour une période de
dix ans des droguées puis les les
et rendent en état d'ébriété avancé il
fait en sorte que la mémoire elle est
moins nord c'est moins précis d'un
témoignage c'est plus confus sa side le
prédateur finalement à sa sortie jack du
côté de l'ungava en 2016
un aide cuisinier du centre de santé
tous là ta vie qu est arrêté 28 oddo 34
ans est accusé d'agressions sexuelles
sur deux jeunes femmes de 17 et 18 ans
il ne se présente pas au tribunal et
fuit le nunavik un mandat d'arrêt émis
contre lui en ou 2017
cinq mois plus tard le service de police
de la ville de montréal lui met la main
au collet
il est remis en liberté après avoir payé
une caution de 200 dollars il était
censé être assigné à résidence à
montréal
mais lorsque nous sommes passés chez lui
personne ne résidait à cette adresse
nous avons appris que 28 au dos a été
arrêté à montréal le 24 février
il fait face à de nouvelles accusations
d'agression sexuelle sur une mineure
d'enlèvement et de séquestration
que ce soient des sujets dans sexuel ce
soit les taux de suicide que ce soit des
problèmes d'alcool que ce soit des
problèmes de violence peu de personnes
au sud de mons suivent
malheureusement ce qui se passe dans le
nord du québec
si loin les réseaux d'information sont
moins présents donc les formations
chemine pas toujours vers le sud
c'est chez nous oui mais on s il en est
au québec mais je peux vous dire ma pas
connaissance personnelle que il ya des
événements des examens majeur ex
produisant ghana et le même événement se
produirait dans une grande ville au sud
quatre aides à une banane semaine date
est ici tu n'entends pas parler du tout
est ce que le nunavik
loin des regards sur un terrain de jeu
pour les pervers
parce que ça pourrait être un terreau
fertile aux
des réseaux pédophiles absolument fin
décembre 2017
l'équipe d'enquêté sur l'exploitation
sexuelle des enfants sur internet de la
sûreté du québec
arrêté à sherbrooke un homme de 29 ans
pedrag riz meech l'homme fait face entre
autres à des accusations de possession
et distribution de pornographie juvénile
l'accusé a travaillé entre autres auprès
des jeunes dans un centre de
réhabilitation à saint-louis tu là est
ce qu a lancé un appel à tous pour
obtenir de l'information sur un match
sans succès ces bois ouest rentable des
années mais lui ça alors on est dans le
vif au sein chebbi on a toad les doigts
les droits de la personne y'a personne
doit demain toucher ni personne ici t'as
pas la loi vous bac et pour vous des
idées ça continue
l'italie femmes sont folles de la police
d'aller parler à la police
ça vient pour plus difficile
les femmes sont pas protégés de la même
manière son nom parce que les polices ou
s'il vient ici la police aussi fait des
choses comme ça parce que c'est 10 juin
que vient ici puis pense comme ça c'est
pas juste des contrats quand tu as
beaucoup du monde que façon le chef de
police du nunavik michelle martin
confirme qu'il ya actuellement des
policiers sous enquête la police et pour
exalter la 2de plein vis-à-vis certains
policiers pour des comportements d'ordre
sexuel deux policiers oui avec des
mineurs non mais de femmes
inwi est ce que vous savez le nombre de
cas en ce moment il y en a deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la réalité des jeunes filles et des
femmes au nunavik est aux antipodes de
ce qui se vit au sud
pourtant ce sont nos compatriotes il y
en a bien sûr qu'ils font leur chemin
comme jamie foxx l'i7 chasseuse de
caribous qui a complété ses études et
travail aujourd'hui auprès des jeunes
saint prosper
le gouvernement de compter six secondes
après le tir
grosse tête
il faut respecter
sans garde fou d'un événement aux
inspecteurs
où
oh
uniterre
ans
cette grand-mère qui s'amuse avec son
petit fils c'est à n'y alla coup cette
année porte le village de saint louis et
sur ses épaules
né dans un igloo et dans la pauvreté
elle a réussi à compléter des études en
éducation et travail social à
l'université mcgill
dans les années 90 elle est directrice
de l'école du village
lorsqu'elle apprend que 11 petites
filles ont été victimes d'attouchements
de la part du chauffeur de l'autobus
scolaire un hymne au prix elle le
confronte il lui répond tout simplement
que cela fait partie de la culture inuit
aimait le film arrive au moins je
retourne là les leucocytes aura un
moteur permanent au match et son mari
l'acteur elle l'a amené à gimat bohain
années a besoin d'un mélomane thèmes
locaux car à partir de ce moment annie à
la couv a consacré sa vie à faire de la
prévention auprès des jeunes et des
femmes et les inciter à dénoncer les
agressions sexuelles c'est une bataille
de tous les instants que nous obtenons
aura un épais torons étape
où
elles me permettent ce manoir hovey
dinosaures et l'initiateur des
ajustements ram
nous y sommes et valeurs méthane à magna
il n'y en a pas mal à la main des lignes
alors j'ai mal agi mais il n'est à mes
ennemis à tort la victoire est
l'initiateur acteurs stop un bâtonnet
line observateurs ports et leurs annie
alakoua aussi été agressée par un homme
blanc malgré les années la douleur est
toujours aussi vive
[Musique]
alina madalina et originale aux appels
m
en effet l'on maîtrise et à ses agents
sur sa poitrine tamani top actus aspect
compagnie josias météoritique scooter
avec nos trois semaines en allemagne
noiseux wyman femme de sam
wada
et rémy
many many years
soit m
internet est qu après la pause des
femmes inuites qui veulent dénoncer la
situation se bute à l'omerta de leurs
leaders
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'isie a loupé à est agent de prévention
auprès du corps de police régionale
kativik
cette femme est un autre pilier plus
nunavik ssp stefan sahm ramda communauté
avec willy van noten think thank you i'm
happy offrit un tel talent novateur
lisibles ou pas est l'une des femmes
responsable du programme goes touch bat
tod qui enseigne aux enfants a dénoncé
des comportements inappropriés
sa mort est à moi
où as tu l as we have to choose de
wisteria lane i have been ordered à pied
pour tous ces acteurs qui n'ont pas du
tout
[Musique]
dénoncer parler publiquement demeure
encore un geste difficile et pas
toujours encouragé par certaines
instances au nunavik nous avons
rencontré l'une des jeunes leaders du
nunavik elle a voulu inciter les femmes
à dénoncer le comportement de certains
travailleurs son employeur l'a sommé de
se taire sous peine de perdre son emploi
elle nous a quand même fait suivre ce
message plusieurs organisations et
leader empêche les gens de partager
leurs expériences et proposer des
solutions
en agissant de la sorte ils permettent
aux comportements négatifs de perdurer
dans notre région
une enseignante de cellou et voulait
dénoncer le harcèlement de certains
travailleurs de la construction à
l'endroit de ces jeunes étudiantes
elle n'a pas eu la permission de la
commission scolaire kativik pour le
faire et aucun porte parole n'a voulu
commenter cette décision
tous les étés de jeunes adolescentes de
saluer devons passer quelques semaines
dans un camp de l'autre côté de la baie
en
elles sont ici entourés d'aînés qui leur
transmettent certaines valeurs et
traditions
il n'y aura pas qu'ils nous retrouvons
sur color line up in all thy bonne idée
alors du mal à m'y mette
or avec horreur de me rendre à leur da
il est aussi vital que nos lois mais ils
n'ont aucune envie de cannes est qu un
peu normal et je désire démarré alors de
bamako autonomie
chris weitz riz
[Musique]
slade
ayew pro b nos coeurs
oui
[Musique]
mission à macao
à l'époque romaine
- tintin
[Musique]
josé votre reportage est absolument
bouleversant mais qui se termine quand
même avec une note d'espoir ces
femmes-là de la communauté qui semble
vouloir faire avancer les choses changer
les choses mais elles vous ont parlé
également d'un autre phénomène les bébés
de la construction oui vous savez ces
jeunes femmes là ils jouent les femmes
inuites vont tomber en amour avec des
travailleurs la construction ça arrive
c'est des belles histoires des fois mais
souvent c'est par ici proc
alors ces hommes là vont retourner après
la saison de construction vont retourner
dans le sud retrouver leurs femmes et
leurs enfants puis vont laisser derrière
ben des femmes qui vont avoir des bébés
des femmes qui n'auront pas d'être
financière qui n'auront pas la
reconnaissance du père alors ça aussi ça
cause des problèmes pour pour ces femmes
là ouais c'est un aspect vraiment qu'on
soupçonne pas de cette réalité là merci
beaucoup josé pour votre enquête
merci à la maison d'avoir été là on
espère que vous avez apprécié le
reportage et on vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]